hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to rain world now rain world
is a game made by Adult Swim games and
if you know about built Swim and the
games they make the last game that I
remember was rainbow unicorn attack but
I know they've made a ton of other games
since then and I'm willing to give this
game the benefit of the doubt and not
even that oh hey well that's so pretty
I'll be so pretty and not that there's
doubt to be given because of course
they're gonna make fun games no matter
what this one in particular is very
different because it looks so pretty and
the main character that you play is one
of these snake-like rabid cat creatures
that are just absolutely adorable and
apparently this world oh it's a baby oh
that's a baby on your arm oh it's so
cute little family oh and the reason I
like oh they're hunting Oh bats are moms
I can't tell oh oh he's biting my head
off now and oh my god oh that's so I
guess they gotta eat some up but I want
to play this one because it's so like
artistically driven and in my mind and
this is because my own vile is because
my own bias oh oh no oh god I was just
watching I'm emotionally compromised
already
well then poor wholesome family all the
wholesome meme that was that family oh
no oh that's who we play oh I thought
this was going to be like a tragic story
of this family that just loses every
member of their family but maybe that's
because I've been playing too many dark
games like to have a little more
optimism about this but this game is
supposedly very very challenging because
number one oh all hi I'm a snake cat ah
oh I got a map I got a map pick up eat
throw jump not a lot to do here but this
is supposedly very - oh look at my dinky
danke twinkle toes
was oh god I don't even walk gotta hold
forth oh I use it for guru what the hell
okay I'm very slang key you're hungry
fine food is blue food
can I eat blue I don't know how to find
food oh hello are you food can I eat you
what are you okay ah I'm so swanky Oh
what are you doing what are you doing oh
you're giving me advice well I was gonna
try to eat you okay I can climb up the
ropes and whatnot it's very quiet
the low level oh can I eat you I
remember my parents eating you remember
very late bite your head off here I
could've sworn this was this was the eat
button I'm pressing that eat but did I
eat it I guess I ate it uh you're
trapped now got you um num num num can I
can i nom you I'm mashing it oh I gotta
hold it down and then I bite it to
pieces
well that's incredibly morbid but I'm
gonna do it anyway um yeah um okay
here demurred you know I'm not a trip it
swings off first
Oh horrifying body just one left before
is enough to hibernate with apparently
it's here wait they're here I know there
y'all know get you Georgia got you too
bad for you I'm funny okay all right
additional food above for is kept for
later in my belly in the form of fat
alright well thank you for all the
information
yellow weird fungal creature that gives
me advice and is also computerized thank
you for that oh so supposedly supposedly
I say it's supposedly guaranteed there
are a lot of things that don't want me
to live in fact they may even want to
eat me are you gone hey I come back here
were you running off to
hey I ate your whole family I lost my
family therefore I have no problem
with that idea I'm coming for you I got
you you're shooting up gonna come up
here to my feeding grounds I guess I
could just catch it hold it
I don't know why I do that and let me go
up here first I know you got some advice
for me to do but I just want to leap up
the gap
I'll try what happened to my food did I
eat it already I can't even remember all
apparently I did okay how do I leap with
the gap whoa get windy damn nope that's
not how you do it hey yeah thank you for
teaching me how to be me that's so cool
I'm ass lanky cat oh my god I'm new what
is happening okay
hello why is it like that why is it like
that why is it like that why is it okay
I don't know what's happening I don't
know what happening what the hell is
that I don't know what that is I go down
here okay what is this what's going on
okay all right oh boy I don't know
what's happening
hello this place is safe stay here to
hibernate oh god but what about my
family
oh okay yeah I feel real safe with all
the machinery is locked up beside me
okay so the answer is fine I'm in
upside-down today I'm gonna move on to
Japanese symbol that I don't understand
and then I need for food every time I
want to hibernate and then it unlocks
thankfully thank you good thing all this
machinery is here for me so this speaks
to another level in case you guys like
don't know like or maybe I'm crazy but
this speaks to another level of what's
going on here there's food and shelter
to be found but beware of predators go
explore Thank You Guardian I guess I'm
gonna just do my thing oh nice clue with
light in the background I like that
honest so pretty
are so pretty but we're obviously in
some sort of post-apocalyptic world this
is the shell of a society that came
before us look if that's super weird
objects can be taught huh I taught it
real good yeah okay why do I toss it ah
good I'm your foot get you huh yeah see
ya you're gone right no no no no no no
that's all you hear there was another
one there you go oh oh they bury on the
ground oh God
so being a goof got you both mm it's a
feast
all right numb okay so if I get down if
I jump up oh hello where am I going
where am i slacking off too
laughs of all I got a spear nobody mess
with me apparently I got a spear
so what's lurking around in the darkness
hello hi what are you try to tell me
here oh there's some sort of generator
down there ah but I'm not hundreds if
not hundreds and sure how to do that oh
here we go where I'm just in a hole in
the ground I'm just gonna stay here for
a while all righty then seven key all
right
down no god damn it come on you slinky
cat
stop being so whoa what the [ __ ] is that
homeboy well that terrifying where they
come from
boskie I made it can I go up here I
don't know where this is gonna know
that's not gonna work cricket dick stop
sliding off everything you got other
things to worry about apparently I'm
gonna hold onto this rock see I know
what I gotta do I know I'm a well aware
of it blurted nope man let me really
think about this but nope let me throw
this ah got you good scared you didn't I
yeah I could we're not jumping no why am
I not leaping leap elegantly leap like a
gazelle leap that god damn it you left
then but not close enough
yes son of a badger come on we gotta get
over there got it
lead nope okay I got a really wait leap
deep bleep hot damn it leap Brickton
leap
goddammit what a different gun is not
doing it why why - ok ok let's not be an
idiot about this right now do I need to
get back to the shelter but I just okay
I'm gonna get back to the shelter I
suppose Oh Oh get down oh boy
ok alright then I'll get back to the
shelter Oh God
ok that's following me huh it's not the
right way to go is it I don't know you
following me huh alrighty then I think
I'm okay maybe not that I don't think
it's still up there I am pretty sure it
is okay alright then
everything seems fine so I got a leap
across the chasm again but hopefully not
into the Maz of death that'd be nice
yeah alright
yes starting to get the hang of this it
is a bit it is a bit hard to control
sometimes like I'm not gonna deny it is
who I can pick up another stick here and
then not throw it that'd be that'd be a
good idea they're not throw when I don't
need to throw it ah a means of escape oh
yeah yeah yeah you don't know I'm here
do you God
maybe he does oh he's slang key - no no
no no no no no no no no okay or you
don't know I'm here
I like that ah you don't even try it
oh god oh god oh god oh god oh god oh
god okay okay alright alright going this
way going this way they both went that
way which means it this way is probably
okay right that's how this works
oh please don't screw up my jobs please
don't screw up my jobs Oh on ye okay
where am I why is it all shaky are the
rains coming back here what's happening
not that one you douche ah
wait is it where's it going Oh God
okay where did he go you pop it out I
don't dress it hey is that the range do
I need to get back I don't know where
I'm going it's over it's the rains it's
the Rings oh god I'm an idiot what have
I done
get out of here get out get out get out
I don't know where these are taking
these that's not where I want to go Oh
Frick a dick come on it's raining oh I
guess it's not hey I guess is everything
okay oh that's out now oh god damn Oh
God
ow we're kind of heavy rain [ __ ] is bad
ah Wow and just like that you're gone
Jesus was in my corpse okay where else
doing that over all right let's try to
do this a little less like a baby and
let's try to survive like an adult
whatever the hell species I am yeah all
right so I got to get food again cuz I
died again but at the same time now I
know where to go maybe and then I'll be
able to do what I gots to do okay all
right there we go got that point I got
that barely by the hair on my chinny
chin Jen you sleep you better be asleep
over there huh with your twitchy head
you doing over there ah oh god oh god oh
god I didn't get in the hole ah okay
come on I guess uh why are you following
me
Rick a dick okay I think we're fine they
were fine because if I can just I don't
fall like an idiot I should be okay uh
that doesn't look good
oh well yeah yeah yeah yeah you can't
get me yeah here we go perfect up right
on the first try Oh what an idiot you
god damn it god god dammit god dammit
god dammit don't even try it don't even
try it boy oh boy oh this is a dead end
isn't it ah okay alright then let's try
this
what is that Dongen god there's so much
food here but I don't need you uh I'm
I'm a nervous wreck right now I mean
number one I don't have my family with
me how did I do that sweet backflip cuz
that was pretty awesome if I could
remember how to do that I might be able
to capitalize on it mmm
barn key okay let's try this again ye
boi key okay I don't know how you got
over the not that one god damn it
God get out no this doesn't look good
hey buddy how about you uh oh boy oh boy
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy no no no no
oh no no oh god oh god ah hiiiiii oh god
oh god oh god oh god oh you're so scary
why are you so carry cheese on what are
you gonna do huh are you gonna do buddy
you gonna do huh nothing you gotta do
nothing to me yeah that's right back off
back off I got a rock gonna rock
I'm a rock in the face buddy oh you want
a rock into who you want to rock in the
face oh [ __ ] [ __ ] you up ah Oh God
alright Danny let's let's uh let's let's
agree to disagree on that one because I
think I won that fight I'm pretty sure I
won that encounter yeah I don't think
anybody's gonna be mad at me for letting
him live and it's the moral choice I'm
stuck my head got caught on my own ass
are you doing in that corner over there
doesn't that doesn't look appropriate
ake the bat pick the back go okay here
we go
I'm gonna make it decide
wait so you can just go up there wait so
you can just wait I tried to do that
well I tried to do that oh god oh god oh
god what I tried look I tried to do that
it didn't let me well is that about I
tried it you know where I am you do oh
boy oh boy go go go
Frick I'm dead but I tried to do that so
I've been doing it the hard way that no
one's supposed to go that way oh man
it's just gonna show him eating me oh
it's just gonna show I'm dragging my
corpse error aware oh oh
[Music]
where are you taking me
where's it taking me I know I can
restart at any time I'm just like I just
want to find out where it's taking me
you know in a weird cosmic sense you
know this isn't any different than what
I'm doing to those bats there cuz I kill
and eat those bats so what does it
really matter
well I like how this little yellow guy
is still following me around oh don't
fight over my corpse oh whoa
what the Frick was there huh okay
they're just gonna fight over me oh boy
oh they're literally fighting to the
death over my corpse Oh what the hell
okay
I'm it's good to know that I'm worth
this even in death okay so I'm going to
take this very intelligent path right
here not that one that would be that's
not the intelligent path okay and then
well I don't know what I found really
cycle one outskirt i god damn it
freaking guy okay alright then oh boy oh
boy oh boy oh boy oh boy
back flip back flip the [ __ ] out of here
back flip into the next year oh [ __ ]
wrong hole again god dammit I keep going
in the wrong goddamn hole
[Music]
right but anyway I'm where I died to the
rains at least sweet backflips oh you
want some of this huh you want some of
this bro you want you want some of this
you can't handle no know that I got a
rock god damn spear you want a piece on
me right yeah you can handle this you
could never handle this you don't even
know what handling this looks like so
why don't you just lay down let me be my
life okay anyway got you I don't even
know want you but okay I got you I guess
all right so where to go here I guess
the only way to go would be up whoa oh
so good such an acrobat I guess all you
I don't really want to be God not bad
why would you throw that not the bat all
right fine I got another stick done Matt
it's all good down here maybe uh and
then maybe by climb out on this thing oh
ah okay I got you okay I got it
I don't understand I don't understand
but I I'm gonna act like I understand
and if I go down this way
sneak do Weeki like this and then I go
down this way I've made my way farther
I don't know fathers Gazoo hey buddy hey
buddy hey buddy hey buddy hey buddy hey
buddy whoa whoa whoa whoa hey whoa whoa
whoa whoa aah that's equally as bad aah
oh my god [ __ ] it's so scary man all
right I'm starting at the hang of this
game everyone ignore the fact that I've
banned a bunch
and let's get to the heart of the matter
which is going wherever the hell I need
to go I just saw the green one Oh green
ones - yeah how can you do that to me
how could you do that to me go go go go
go go go
Jesus go go um [ __ ] go hey yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] go
it's scary this is scary
skewered okay all right then Danger
Danger Danger I know I know I know not
that one not that brung [ __ ] ho yeah
goddamn goober no don't do that no don't
no don't do that either do the opposite
of all those things okay doesn't know
I'm here
okay all right you gonna move okay no
you didn't see any what are you doing oh
they're all coming after me okay all
right just uh flip-flop my way through
here this tube is good you're not
supposed to be here all righty then but
do you know I'm here I hope not
how could you how would you all right
it's gonna do some sweet backflips shred
had to die horribly no don't just jump
okay yeah
yeah you thought you were gonna thought
you're gonna chase after me the answer
was you not and then you got screwed out
of a meal aren't you stupid feel hey
there's a lot of Pat's on that one I
said that's where they hide oh why did
you do back flips off of that what did
you suddenly backflip what did you do 10
million backwards why would you do that
now he's just gonna stand there ah
so mad now Danny he's in the one place I
need to pray okay where you are god damn
it I don't know what's happening he's
got me okay well walk why would he back
slap wedge in a nanana nanana slinky den
NNN NNN Annette vegan dananananana don't
eat me
oh [ __ ] dude it's you I like green skin
it's really cool now don't eat me look
at me balancing like badass dirt dander
dander doodoo don't eat me you son of a
[ __ ] ass or to turn to dirt dirt dirt
dirt or to dirty - oh god oh god oh god
miss me miss me you big fat douche
Big Daddy boo-boo milk and a crime this
goddamn pole now fifty big [ __ ] me yeah
oh god oh god oh god yeah you miss me
you stupid [ __ ] I got nothing against
you please don't kill me I don't want to
die oh god please don't kill me
oh [ __ ] alright ah hi you dummy hi you
Donny
okay let me know it's just not backflip
not that cliff would be good you oh my
god you almost did it okay so for some
reason when you like land on the ground
sometimes you do a sweet flip and that
[ __ ] I wanted that damn it I don't want
rocks I wanted to throw the rock so I
could have this stick but you know what
sometimes you just don't get sick you
just don't get sick like that's that's
life that's all they're fighting are you
fighting over something or are you just
fighting in general I'm gonna sneak gone
by you now that's better do boo boo fail
Hey look at me I'm dancing on a pole now
pepper dip down Oh pal but not like that
it's kind of cool I guess what video
okay miss me [ __ ] you [ __ ] you buddy I'm
going up here now boo doo de doo doo doo
doo look at all these [ __ ] poles
paternal orders dr. Acrobat is my
profession doo doo boo boo boo not this
hole you stupid [ __ ] all right here we
go
boink boink boink
oh that is it okay I don't know where
we're going but we're making a lot of
profit I made it to another side no oh
god oh god oh god get up there huh oh
yeah okay maybe it was all a lie what
the Frick is that what was he saying
about this area but there was another
safe house over there whose stick I like
a stick on a really well one of those
guys with this stick here okay I don't
know what those sounds are that I'm
hearing but I see you well I'm not going
in there when you're in there oh you
think I'm a dumb dumb and I'm just gonna
waltz into your mouth oh not today
not D not today baby not today
oh boy he's coming after me how about a
big ol stick to the face oh god he liked
it he liked it he liked it I didn't know
he'd like it I was under the impression
that he would not love God did I just
rob or knocked myself oh god damn it
the [ __ ] wall jump I was never good
at this good okay all right so we're in
a conundrum right now oh boy don't know
how to get away from it
ooh boy oh boy all right you wanna you
want to go with me you bastard I'm going
to go no no no no no okay so we got a
bit of an issue here seem to be a little
off
huh he did not know too stupid I see ah
you went the wrong way I have the high
ground you can't possibly win okay okay
we got to get up there because
apparently the guy is telling us that
something's up there and and you know I
do I always do what I'm told so here we
go slank in our way Oh does that mean
halfway done we got to get back soon I
got time off I'm on my way to us
I'm following the yellow brick road oh
hello I hope I'm going the right way
oh I will be able to get up here okay
this was a long convoluted path to get
up here
ah right go and go and go and go and go
and go and I feel like I've made a lot
of stress right now I don't like it too
much but here we go
boink what's up here whoa what's up
there what is that
what's this hologram well just show it
to me I don't know what that means but
I'm gonna go for it I've trusted you
thus far where am I
OOP ado climbing up ol doo doo doo doo
doo doo doo the Frick is all this
it's not comforting that there's just an
alarm going off the flood is bad what is
that Oh God
oh that's what the alarm was oh I think
those are the day symbols so I can't
come back here until those days which is
just about to happen now oh but I'm far
away oh god it really screwed me over on
this one I've got it how do I get up
there oh I can't get up there again
ha-ah no I can't I can't do it I got to
go this way oh man but am i safe from
the rains in here no probably not
where am I I don't know where I am not
that one maybe it was that one it was
that one god
goddamn it I'm sorry I'm such a panic
right now I got to get back because
otherwise all this progress is gonna
mean nothing I'm gonna die where am I
now G what is G mean I don't know what G
means you come away from all the
Predators Jesus okay I'll go up here I
guess I don't know where am I now
oh you wanna you wanna you want to
frickin stick to the face I will stick
you so good hmmm you ain't gonna know
what don't stick you yeah that's right
you better run
alright so if I get up here and then
freakin yeah no that didn't work
oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy you
want to get sticked oh boy dad get up
off rock this is hard it's like really
really really hard he's taking me to his
GE cave goddamn it
not the g-spot [ __ ] alright so this is
really hard there's like ridiculously
hard
because one I don't know the levels and
I don't know the lamp but it's so it's
so intriguing like it's just really
intriguing what and what is wrong with
you purple freaks what is wrong with you
what do you twitch what he who's
radiation and what are the symbols mean
I'm just a weird slinky cat I'm a snake
bunny
I've been a anyway that's all the time I
got for this episode but this is really
really interesting I want to play more
this I want to play so much more this is
so cool I don't even know what it is
about it because I don't know the
universe but that's what makes it cool
why am I here where did all this
machinery come from one of those
creatures where's my family
would my dad be able to kick their ass
my bet is yes huh what this is cool want
to play more so I'm going to play more
so thank you everybody so much for
watching let me know what you think down
the comments below and as always I will
see you in the next bye bye
[Music]